one day he's evil but he's our evil dr.
Frank Luntz is over here dr. dr. it is
great to see you doctor
now Frank are you really a doctor yes I
have a detail from Oxford University
really and I actually have one this is
really you're not like reverend al
sharpton you're you're actually a doctor
okay all right
it was I and you're wearing high-top
sneakers of different colors yes Frank
you're too old for that you're just
that's just not a good luck could I do
some polling on those shoes the
difference they suck okay those shoes
are really bad Frank would anyone like
them yeah
well don't don't take anyone like yeah
okay all right so Frank let's I need
these I actually I need these it's these
are - these are tough times are they not
yeah what do you mean I don't get it
these if I can't I look down at these
and I realize that it looks like I'm
colorblind basically but I need this I
need to this to get through the day I
don't know what you're talking about
Frank odd politics and more importantly
I don't care let's talk let's talk about
let's talk about what you you know
you're the expert you're the guy who
knows what's going on
I saw all week it is now tied Trump and
Hillary forty forty explain this to me
how an insane racist in orange
greasepaint can be tied with the former
first lady the valedictorian at Wesleyan
Secretary of State New York senator 40
40 what is going on here and who's the
other 20 the the challenge for her quite
frankly is she's not authentic
she's not straightforward Bernie Sanders
said what he meant meant what he said
Bernie Sanders should have been the
Democratic nominee
and Bill frankly Bernie Sanders should
have run as a third party candidate
let's that's and the reason why is that
he is a clearly defined set of
principles he is a clearly defined set
of ideas and that Hillary Clinton is a
corporate Democrat and you would have
had three distinctly different
philosophies well and why not okay
because he would lose for sure you know
no third party candidate has a chance in
this country you don't think Mike you
don't think Mike Bloomberg could have
won no of course not why not he was a
great mayor of New York he was not a
great may was a great Mary is very
successful in New York okay buddy no no
think come on Frank you're telling me a
third party catechu here's the point
forty percent of the people the
Republicans are voting for Donald Trump
which chose you they will vote for
anyone anything with an AR by the name
and they would vote for Jared from
Subway and 40 percent and 40 percent are
voting for Hillary Clinton but you know
the FBI director said top it had engaged
in in nearly criminal activity for he
what we didn't say that what he's he
obviously what he said Frank was that no
prosecutor would bring charges he it's
none of them yeah that's what he said
you have a responsibility honestly and
he's a republic and this is and this is
and he serves a Democratic president and
he's done it well and he presented his
evidence serve a Democratic president if
you think the Attorney General is who
appointed him the head of the FBI who
appointed him Obama right so he serves a
Democrat he serves I realized I realize
that you've got the humor you got the
advantage Jonah but the fact is a polite
me or I are so many Americans so angry
why are so Americans so angry why are
they so friends people like you elect
Republic why are they pissed off 25
that's funny the last time I looked
barack obama wasn't a republican yeah
they're not managing he's got a rather
high approval rates approve ratings 50%
let's hire them bushes and reagan's was
at this point actually no that's not
true ronald reagan's roots at 61% at
this point when he left office barack
obama's at 50% Reagan left office at 61
at least get the facts right I don't
remember that I look not even close drew
the it
why are we so divided why are we so
angry why do so many people feel
Democrats feel that their voice isn't
heard feel that Wall Street doesn't
represent them feel that Washington
doesn't represent them I've been going
through the last three or four years but
you and I agree on so much even though
you don't wanna admit it even though
it's because it's good for laugh baby we
agree on Isis we agree that what
happened in Nice is is disgusting we
agree that we need to [ __ ] up these
people who are screwing with Americans
right now we need to defend our military
we should speak up for a men and women
in uniform and that in the end this
threat against us I'm not sure I think
with by the forum you don't agree that
that Isis is a threat you know we don't
agree that we have a problem in national
security I agree Isis is a threat so but
so let's do something let's not just sit
back I'll be cannot we cannot be
diplomatic
we actually have but you say answer your
question why people are so angry mostly
it's because they're ignorant no
obviously there are things I can't do
that
I think that's wrong yes I'm not gonna
sit and insult this country well I don't
know I always have yes
it's called real time I understand that
people judge on what's going on just
because they don't have a degree from
Oxford University wasn't making ignorant
fifty-five people who come and sweep up
this audience when they all leave that
people come and clean up this place have
just as much of a right to vote as you
and I top it you don't agree that that's
right Frank I'm against the people who
clean up this place no but that those
are the let's bring the straw man out
here shall we
Frank would you like to peaceful
Strummer the people who worked the
camera right there that your camera rice
sitting right there yes yes the show's
over I take a [ __ ] right on them fellas
because that's who I am I [ __ ] on the
little people that's how they feel and
that no they don't
yes they do bill you know what you know
what people think I was here you're
still just hope right here so yours
audience feel there's a polling here's
some polling 55 percent of Republicans
think Barack Obama is sympathetic to
terrorist groups like a 79 percent of
statistics are made up on the spot
that's not a statistic that's polling so
you're a pollster you don't believe that
I don't believe that no really no now
you're just you're just saying what you
don't want to believe is not true
aye-aye-aye poll because so many of the
polling we get about Obama firmer
puppets is the same thing they believe
he's a Muslim they believe he's from
Kenya he's not legitimate
why don't you think 55 percent of
Republicans in the last poll think Obama
is sympathetic to Isis I mean from
Christ's sake that's when Trump says all
the times my whole life is spent out
with the American people my whole life
is spent focus grouping and polling and
interacting with them and listening to
them and I'm not a humorous you're
getting it I don't tell the jokes but
what I do here I'm not telling jokes
either but don't you see that these
divisions how serious it is that we have
divisions between 25 year olds and 55
year olds we have divisions in terms of
income those divisions in terms of
education and that we should be seeking
ways to bring people together I don't
understand why everything a first
election well it's not people people are
I find it amusing that someone who works
for Fox News and is a lifelong Republic
for CBS News is talk you just Eve never
so you never miss news I said you were
on and on Monday yes you'd never work
for Fox News I work for Fox and CBS I
work okay so but you're just saying once
again you're trying to demonize I'm not
trying to demonize exactly you know edit
you're trying to get a laugh no are
trying to demonize
that's demonizing to say everything I
say is not valid because I'm a comedian
so can do urine on your attack
it's how come every time I speak it's an
attack what I was going to say is you're
talking about bringing the country
together do you really think the
Republican Party are the ones who have
been bringing the country together in
the last twenty to thirty years both
sides
you really think Donald Trump who wants
to build a wall and deport 11 million
people and a ban on Muslims you think
that is bringing people together I mean
you're a messenger from an party to be
making this case it's interesting to me
that you have tens of millions of people
who've never voted Republican in their
life that these are people who always
identify with a Democratic Party because
they're working class you know I have
much savings they don't have much income
and they've always voted for every
Democrat this is the first time you
think that they are voting for Donald
Reagan Democrats 40 percent Reagan got
40 percent 39 to be specific so what
what is that [ __ ] about the furnace
on this is the first time that a
majority of the working class are
actually gonna vote Republican well we
don't know what happened before what
what you did there you know this for a
fact a majority of the working lesson
cannabis is the first time this is why
because all right because Trump is
losing upper-middle class voters it's
gonna win no I don't you want him to win
what I want you said mean things about
you I know that and you know it so of
you I'm still on your show I know but
but you who do you who's gonna win
you're the man if the election is held
today Hillary Clinton would win by three
points
it's not held today tell me what the
rules are in the debate if you tell me
what the rules are I tell you who wins
no flinging your poop you're right Frank
I make joke sometimes well thank you
very much I wish I have more time
great once everybody